go back to you know we were saying like
the motive because I feel like you said
something I had a friend of mine and by
the way we had the Kevin Farley here
last week Chris Farley's brother and
obviously we know what happened with
Chris he was also heroin and they tried
to get to him over and over and over
again and then they eventually couldn't
33 years old boom it's done and we lost
one of the greatest uh of all time but
what was because because I had a friend
that went through it and we talked about
it with Kevin and his deal was Vicodin
he couldn't give it up but he was taking
25 to 50 a day it wasn't like he was
taking one or two he was taking 25 I've
seen him take 10 like this and just put
in his mind like it's candy right he was
doing that uh and he couldn't go without
it he was addicted to we took him to a
Tarzana Rehabilitation said you know
which one there's a Tarzana rehab center
and he will have to go through for two
weeks he came out he was good boom a
week later he's reading the Bible
relapse done and we get the phone call
and uh it's a good friend of mine okay
my best friend in the world anyway so
but but the point is I I kept trying to
get his motive and it has to be him yeah
so so he was he was marrying a girl that
he loved I'm like do you love is the
love that strong that you're willing to
change for her I don't know if it was
you know he had reasons with his dad and
his mom he had a bro you know I'm like
maybe career maybe identity maybe it's
what what it like would we took him to
church to see maybe churches because you
know a lot of times it's Church a lot of
people
have given up a lot of drugs and alcohol
because of a connection they had
spiritual connection to Catholics
Mormonism Scientology Christian it
doesn't matter there's so many great
stories even Scientology has that one
place in in uh uh what do you call it
the arrowhead I think it's Arrowhead
right like uh where there's a facility
there that you're going through drugs or
rehab that you go through and it's
actually very effective I've heard it
from a lot of different people that it's
worked for them but there has to be
something on the individual right nobody
can impose you so you better get it done
what's the matter with you're gonna kill
yourself that's not gonna work what what
was your so I I you know it's hard to
say because in this conversation you
have people who are listening who are
going like I know a guy who I need that
guy to have whatever I had and I just
don't know if there's a formula to
create that in an individual I think
it's possible to present data and
solutions and like when you're ready
we're here you know I I've got I've got
a plan that you can follow but I I do
believe until the individual is ready
themselves
I had multiple interventions run on me
it nothing I I
would go to sleep at night for for a
couple of years believing I was gonna
die in my sleep and was just like well
that's what it is and none of that
changed and I woke up one day and was
just I I I was in need of change I I
woke up and I could not exist the way I
was existing anymore and I'm so thankful
that I didn't die before that day
happened and then likewise
food and and that health and my weight
was another thing that like no matter
what evidence people presented to me and
what Solutions were presented to me I I
didn't change until I was ready to
change having been a drug addict and uh
morbidly obese I've had many parents say
we need help with our kid and this and
that and and there was a period in time
where I would go and talk to people and
talk at schools and stuff like that and
here and and I'm happy to talk and share
my experience but sitting down with
one-on-one and and trying to convince
them to change
that I've always had failures with I
just and I've always seen failures with
this I don't know that it's possible to
convince somebody to change until
they're ready to change now that's not
to say somebody comes and says I'm ready
to change and you go great I can help
you right that's possible but I have not
seen a lot of success with like we need
to we need to handle this guy we need to
fix it I totally agree with you know
what I'm not asking that what I mean
what it was exactly I mean you know what
I'm asking is like if so for me what
I've seen is it's a girl you're in love
with a girl that changes right it's a a
loss of a loved one you lose a parent
you lose somebody you're like dude I got
there's or like for me my biggest like
how I change dude if you would if you
had asked my my counselor in high school
said I feel sorry for your dad having
heart attacks but I would also have
heart attacks if I had a son like you
in high school there isn't there's not a
single soul that said I was gonna amount
to anything in life right so I'm not the
guy that's supposed to win so the only
guy that said listen you're not a guy
that's going to do anything with your
life why don't you go join the army guy
named Jesus Giro like it was a
recruiting station down from Glendale
High School because I went to Glendale
High School so he was right off of
Colorado and Verdugo Jesus said hey Pat
I think you need to join the Army you
got a uniform you got something to do
you're going to travel they're going to
pay for it you're going to be able to
get the hell out of here I'm like oh
that's the selling point to me the
selling point was you can get the hell
out of here and just go and I'm like I'm
in right I went in then I got out and
I'm still you know I'm you know
determined to make money I got dreams I
want to do stuff I'm a performer I'm not
like a guy that's sitting around not
doing [ __ ] but
my dad had the heart attack I went to
the hospital I saw my dad on his
deathbed he lost 40 pounds and they
kicked me out of the hospital because
they were not treating them good and the
lady's like who are you who you think
you are you this is a government you're
not paying taxpayers are paying for this
did you pay for this I'm sorry you can't
talk to us like that they came in they
kicked me out of the place I'm in in the
car my Ford Focus I'm crying like a
little baby and it's as if like this the
next time I'm a whole different human
being I came to work and it was done I
went working 80 20. I said I'm not going
to stop till that guy doesn't have to
worry about a single thing about money
and it was game over it's a 180 human
being one minute to the next minute my
friends would call and would go out and
say we missed the old pattern I said
dude I don't miss the old Pat I like the
new pet so you can reminisce about the
old time that guy ain't coming back I'm
committed to this but it was a moment
with my father and I've seen this happen
with a lot of people in my life I'm 43
right now you're 1976 May 25th or May
26th you're 25. so I'm 43 so you see at
43 you see different things on what
causes people to change what was yours
for for and I and I probably don't make
it long term with the drugs without my
wife also like in fairness but it the
the biggest change I saw was me getting
a taste of what my life could be like
with my wife who's now my wife she
wasn't my wife then and wanting it to be
better and that was it that was all it
took for me to go like oh I'm never I'm
never turning you back yeah so how long
have you been with her 20 years and you
were you I'm just I'm sorry you're way
bigger when you met her yeah I met her
when I was 16. fell in love with her
when I was 16. was in the friend zone
for a long time and finally we started
to have a relationship and it was like
the moment we started to have a
relationship I went oh my God
I want to make sure this lasts how do I
make sure this lasts what's the what's
the thing I can do to be the best
partner to her I can possibly be and
that was the biggest change I could make
so it seems like it was and uh once that
like the kind of connection really
happened boom like it's almost like
Pat's story with his dad you I feel bad
relaying that because I can't lend
people my wife to inspire them you know
what I mean like but but that's not but
that's not how I process it bro the way
I process it is
is um
you know this the same goes the other
way like you know uh transparentary
there's a video that's going viral with
chats and Kevin Hart posted it and it's
a sick video he said and I shared it on
Instagram today he said you know in life
you know you can you can try so hard if
you're a winner to get your friends to
win you can introduce you can do it come
on he says you can put all your energy
if that guy doesn't want to do it you
can't do [ __ ] for that guy he said
however however he said a great person
trying to lift somebody that has no
desire won't work he said however
a person with potential who has the
potential a bad person can definitely
demotivate and pull you down to their
level that is effective with everybody
right so crabs in a bucket but but the
point is
I think you know finding the right
person that you say I'm gonna do it for
this person or finding a motivation
that's going to be for that person there
is a message there there is a message to
you know say you know I'm going to do it
for this person because some Sometimes
some personalities we are more like you
know how there's guys that like to fight
and then there's guys I like to stop
fights you know there's guys that are
like hey what'd you say come on let's go
listen and then there's a guy's like I'm
sorry did you touch my friend you touch
my friend are you out of your you you
hit him and then boom you're fighting
for somebody right the flat carrier
mentality of people if they have that
they need to have something to fight for
themselves I don't know if that makes
sense no it does totally and I like what
you said about having a church having a
support group finding a group of people
that are like-minded so if you if you
are alone if you are struggling with
getting motivated I think there are
groups out there that you can go and
become a member even if it's just a gym
and you're like I'm saying hi to that
dude every day and that's who I'm gonna
be accountable I don't know their names
I don't know anything I want to see I
want to make contact with that person
say hello and we're both going to nod
and we're gonna know we're doing this
together to some degree right I do agree
I don't think we're you know no man is
an island there's a beautiful poem no
man is an island and basically it's like
no matter and I believe in in
individualism I am an individualist for
sure but that said none of us function
on our own we're all connected to other
people and there's a symbiotic
relationship that we have with other
people no matter what that's how we are
succeeding and surviving and all of that
yeah let me add one thing about Chaz you
could no I'm good um you're choking up
it's water
um
so for you your motivation was your dad
right for you your motivation was your
wife or the chemistry that you had with
the wife and you didn't want to lose
that feeling
it might for for me it's not always
someone else it sometimes comes down to
what's going on internally so for me
Chas in the movie The Bronx Tale and I I
still like the fact that I met Chaz and
it was on the podcast it was the most
surreal moment and he gave me the card
and on the freaking card it had the
quote that I would write every single
[ __ ] day for years and it would say
the saddest thing in life is wasted
Talent so for me it was more internal
like my fear of mediocrity I did not
want to be average I knew that I had
gifts whether that was with business or
sports or what I used to do stand-up
comedy or like whatever I did like my
biggest motivation was like just don't
be average don't just be just a
run-of-the-mill
blah blah blah person so I no matter
what whatever it was that I ended up
being like do it yeah so what like so
people out there find that motivation
yeah and like the the coming full circle
and the fact that you brought up Chas uh
I I love that guy I mean I still in my
wallet today is the card he gave me your
comfort I'm sorry the saddest thing in
life have you seen the show have you
seen the Chad's show so I watched his
show because you know Bronx Tale started
off as a Broadway show and then it
became a movie and I think Bob saw the
Nero saw it and is like hey what about
if we do this and I play the file your
father and you play you know sunny and I
saw him the play for chess I'm not even
kidding with you he does the entire
movie beginning to the end every line
and he acts everybody in the movie with
one chair if you've never I went to uh
somewhere in Fort Lauderdale by Los
solos to watch this was like a thousand
1200 people in the room I you know how
you know they say you touch your phone
150 times a minute or whatever the
numbers
touch my phone once for 90 minutes right
and I sat there I'm like I cannot
believe I didn't touch my phone it was
re the performance was insane you felt
like you were in the streets with him so
Chad's Chad's props to him for what he's
doing if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]